the president is calling last night's
Senate vote and the shutdown a political
gift this morning the president tweeted
a short time ago that the shutdown is a
nice present from Democrats on the
anniversary of his inauguration major
Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning and
happy Anniversary mr. president your
present on the first anniversary of your
inauguration well it's a partial
government shutdown the first under
one-party rule here in Washington in
decades now the White House and
Republicans are blaming Democrats for
this impasse but if you take a look at
the votes and the speeches it's quite
clear this is a bipartisan mess what's
also clear is Republicans are still
bewildered about what the president's
bottom line is or if it could even be
found the president who last May tweeted
America needed a good shutdown now has
one but so far it's been a downer mr.
Trump canceled a Friday trip to Mara
Lago and a Saturday appearance at a
celebratory fundraiser and anniversary
party last-minute negotiations failed
even after President Trump summoned
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
to the White House the president ignored
questions amid a Friday of uncertainty
even as negotiations with Schumer
commenced White House budget director
Mick Mulvaney blamed him we don't want
this we do not want a shutdown but if
mr. Schumer insists on it he is in a
position to force this on the American
people vice president Mike Pence
continued the finger-pointing on his way
to Egypt Democrats had sent during the
last government shutdown mr. Trump said
the fault was President Obama's he's
never been a deal maker that wasn't his
expertise before he went into politics
and it's obviously not his expertise now
but you have to get the people in a room
and you have to get a deal the White
House predicted a shutdown would be
short-lived the White House emphasizes
this is a partial shutdown as key
federal services including air traffic
control TSA passenger screening law
enforcement and the military will
continue functioning though some federal
employees will be paid later the
Environmental Protection Agency and
Energy Department drawing on budget
reserves will operate at full strength
for a few days entitlement payments
Social Security and Medicare will
continue and museums in Washington will
stay open the White House also assured
that the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention will continue to monitor flu
outbreaks president also on Twitter this
morning said this about the shutdown let
me read it in full Democrats are far
more concerned with illegal immigrants
than they are with our great military or
safety at our dangerous southern border
they could have easily made a deal but
decided to play shut down politics and
said instead about the underlying
question of dreamers in the past the
president said he wanted to treat them
with compassion and only a week ago he
said he was looking for a bill that was
full of love
Anthony major Garrett at the White House
Thank You major